I'm DB Sinclair here with Scott James
and we're about to jump in a match of
hunt looking through the window of
observer mode this is really cool I'm
super excited to see what kind of
features we've got how this is going to
enhance up viewing the game absolutely
speaking of the game of your jumping
right in to the Goliath and as you can
see there's multiple camera angles that
you can use while you're looking at the
Goliath I love the look back behind you
can spin that camera around to look back
behind the glass see the dropship coming
in as the hunters are as well the rest
of the HUD being popped back in there
right now so you can see the camera
selection menu for the hunters of the
monster and even daisy we got a daisy
cam I'm really excited for that day
can't wait to see what uh what she's
doing looks like we've got Kyra pop in
the adrenaline burst the adrenaline
filled we're gonna have them see if they
can catch up the monster here as Cabot
gets the dust tagging on the monster the
monsters would be visible to the team
rest of the team comes in and they get a
dome on the monster immediately and you
can see the hunters bouncing around from
one part of the high ground to another
as you see the traps being laid down by
the trapper below the hunter team doing
a great job of containing the monster in
the middle right now yeah you can see
his odds going down as he's taking
damage as he's losing that armor things
are swaying more towards the hunters
right there Cabot up there get the glory
for himself with that rail cannon you
know he recognizes that Parnell as the
guys gonna take down the monster right
he's gonna put in the assist right true
support it plain to support role there
and helping the entire team do more
damage as we saw there
and the harpoons though just a nice job
by Maggie to get the harpoons
anticipating where the monster is going
to go and laying the harpoons down there
so that they're waiting for the monster
as you can see here you can go
completely cut off or the entire HUD on
with the hut on and in the character
selection menu area we're looking at
health purt purt timer monster armor
monster energy towards evolution and
monster health as well you even see what
stage the monster is right now we have a
stage one Goliath that is finally
getting away on our screen here Scott we
can see that the monster is highlighted
red that's also a feature that you can
turn on or off you'll be able to see the
opponents of the hunter or monster that
you're chasing in the camera across the
map and see what they're up to and where
they're going exactly and you know go
I've got a great bit of distance between
him and the hunters right there that's
going to be huge for him looked like he
was eating there maybe you know there
are a lot of perks back there I know
there's the the tyrant perk the the
health regeneration might have picked
that up you know we're gonna see when it
comes back you can see him he I mean
he's tiny back yeah he's super far away
the rest of the team as we jump from
camera view to camera view from hunter
to hunter we're able to see the action
and see exactly the path that the
hunters are taking the split that
they're doing you see a bunch of trap
drawers here potentially giving the
hunters trouble but they do a nice job
of jetpacking around I love before that
Daisy cam and the marsh strider running
parallel to each other amazing stuff can
happen in this observer mode as you can
see here here's the mobile arena as we
jump to the trapper trapper getting
knocked around by the Goliath but the
rest of the team trying to do damage as
Goliath goes in with the fire breath
exactly live stage 2 here he made his
fire breath a little more powerful it's
going to give you an advantage
absolutely I mean these guys are super
mobile right now they've got a lot of
distich a lot of range on their weapons
go ice is going to need to increase the
range on that fire on my flame breath if
you want to do anything here absolutely
you see the trapper went down so the
trapper now has a strike that's
reflected on the health bar of the
trapper before that though before they
got the trapper back up and the trapper
was
capacitated we saw that familiar skull
slowly bleeding out there letting
everybody know that the trapper needs to
be picked back up and also notice
Daisy's icon as well changes as it does
in the game right now daisy has full
view of the monster pointing at the
monster now is why it's red and flashing
with the monster paw and ! there it is
again trapper goes down once again and
needs to be revived is being revived as
we saw there and comes back up with two
strikes yeah now uh the one thing we do
notice we we've got the those little
icons that indicate that the hunters
have picked up a leaf purse so most of
the team apart from the trapper has got
the damage for now the last got to be
careful here because you as you can see
his mammoth bird cooldown perk is uh
very rapidly running out yeah as are his
odds of survival they just popped up
there alright 35 to 65 now that's that's
because the the monster has such low
health yeah um you know as he gets more
armor his odds are gonna increase and
you know maybe if he can take down one
of these hunters put somebody in the
dropship he's gonna get advantage for
things not looking great for this glass
he's lost quite a bit of his health he's
at stage two so he can get it back but
it's getting closer to the end of the
game I you know it's going to get harder
and harder for him to come back with
that with such low help yeah as you can
see there you can also pop up the map
you can see the pursuit of the hunters
as they are closing in on the monster
also on the monster camera selection
menu section you can see as he was
feeding their his armor building up his
evolved energy building up as well right
now sitting at about half health but
with a lot of armor to work with this
could be a good fight as you see he goes
in and gets the trapper down again
trapper is down and out trapper will be
waiting for the dropship we see the
timer for in the top left hand corner
exact but I think that's going to help
him a lot he's been having a lot of
trouble with those harpooned trap maggie
has been on point with a with laying
those harpooned traps down in just the
right places too to catch a glare I mean
I can't count how many
weeps and leap smashes she stopped with
those harpoon traps yeah absolutely and
speaking of midair with Goliath here in
the the camera pulled back as it is
you're able to almost get a bird's-eye
view of the action on the battlefield
when you're in observer mode and you can
see the true spread of the hunters as
they try and get away we've got Daisy
cam here which will show you exactly
where the monster is as Daisy points to
it while the rest of the team tries to
stay alive trapper down and out assault
very low on health the support on a
strike and the medic doing everything
she can to keep the team alive as she
see she goes flying back into the wall
assault is down Daisy getting attacked
as well we see this is not looking good
for the hunters and look at those odds
sway Scott you talked about the odds the
survival odds before they are now in
favor is the monster as we have to
incapacitation and one hunter completely
down and out exactly i mean they were at
you know 3565 monster and they basically
did a complete turnaround yep and that
just shows how the evan flow of the game
how the game can sway in favor of one
side or the other and how it all is
about forward progress and momentum the
monster came out of that first fight
that first dome with no momentum and
with a lot of loss progress towards its
health and in this case turn it around
in this second mobile arena and really
took the fight to the hunters Swain in
favor stage 2 and some more powerful
abilities definitely helped with that
but not quite enough to clinch it we
come out with a monster win and that's
observer mode coming soon to the evolved
community from turtle rock studios in 2k